>> Hello to all the YouTube community.
I'm Pablo Camacho.
I was the winner of the 2009 Davos Debates.
And I'm addressing you now simply because
I was asked to say a few
words, maybe draw what I can from my experience
of the World Economic
Forum and maybe offer some advice to the new
participants.
This means that now instead of interviewing
Davos attendees, I have to
do something a bit strange and that is interview
myself.
So what should a Davos Debates participant
do?
Well, maybe while pondering what to put in
your video, you could
realize that the most appealing and sort of
striking feature for the
people who are looking for that one winning
entry, could be precisely
that which is not in the video.
That is, that a good response sort of creates
an access meaning both
that it produces lateral discussions, and
more importantly, that it
points towards a sort of potential that seems
bigger than the
three-minute limit on the video.
That sort of potential that surpasses the
contest itself is really
asking to be set loose on an event such as
the World Economic Forum.
But this is actually not what truly matters.
This is sort of just strategy talk.
What becomes really valuable is the way in
which you achieve that and
that is by finding within yourself, your genuine
concerns about the
impending issues right now.
Because when you do that, you sort of then
have everything to say about
it and you can talk forever.
And this is what creates that access that
sort of surpasses the video
and the contest itself.
And it is through this perspective where you
can see how this sort of
gimmicky, strategic context of video contests
actually meets with
honesty, authenticity, and the truthfulness
that is so crucial for this
kind of outsider, citizen figure in an event
such as the World Economic
Forum.
So I hope this can be useful in any way, and
I'd like to take this
chance to prematurely congratulate the winner
and all of you
participants for taking their voice and their
time and transforming
them in public worldwide contributions.